[Music]
I don't really have room oh my oh I'll
just after yeah it should be alright so
what's the plan for today then well I
want to start offering days where people
can come and be a mermaid for a day and
do like an underwater photo shoot and
stuff so I think it'd be really fun to
get you in the water and so you can kind
of experience I was like to be a member
so you've got Paul where we carve it
yeah yes serious kind of essential
pollinating this Jay Ellis levira sorry
that is rising I saw so to become a
mermaid what do you do to just like put
on a pair of flippers and just jump in
the river or what yeah not quite you'll
probably likely to drown if you do that
yeah and I did an open water free diving
qualification and guys they gonzo like
Welsh it's an island off the coast of
Cyprus are all fair DOS I do everything
from children's parties to aquarium
shows and corporate events to underwater
photo shoots so I'm starting a mermaid
camp where people can learn to come and
be a mermaid just sorry I didn't realize
there was so much I could do with it how
long could yoga wrestle at the moment I
have a maximum breath hold of 3 minutes
so in the pool now oh yeah I'll teach
you some of the basics and we'll get
some underwater shots of you yeah let's
hit this bad boy up yeah
do they they'll pour is it I don't know
yeah
[Music]
yeah I'll definitely stick to trucks
yeah Susan breathing is kind of slow
about writing it you know and acts for
the shoots which is breathing three open
alpha six
all right okay let's do this you breathe
in 70% of the air you can breathe it and
so about all out but it will help just
and then endemic chest so I think the
best bet is just gonna to throw you in
the deep end pretty much let's game from
the top really do something fun
[Music]
well that was naturally but that was so
much fun I can't wait to tell like the
lads that I'm a man now yeah so where do
you think the mermaid business is going
at where's where what's the future so
we're gonna be doing some tank shows
with sharks and things so it's gonna be
hot jaws it's fun thank you so much it's
been a pleasure thank you today grace
has really inspired me it's been such an
experience she always wanted to be a
mermaid just become a mermaid she's
turned into a business I always wanted
to be a fire engine domain and never too
late for that so yeah all right see what
happens
oh I see all light a nice one I have a
safe journey home take care ha ha